hey this morning we're taking a look at
how to navigate a very uncertain job
market right now in fact according to a
new LinkedIn survey almost 40 percent of
people out there are worried they're
going to be laid off this year and 20 of
people fully 20 actually expect their
jobs to be gone in the next year
LinkedIn career expert Catherine Fisher
is here to help with some advice all
right Catherine you got laid off what
now well first of all go into the job
market really confident understand that
you were not laid off because of you
personally it was because of business
performance then you need to lean into
that Network you've been building your
contacts all throughout your you know
career ask for help we're seeing a lot
of people on LinkedIn posting that
they've been laid off and where you
really see the comments coming in to
help is when people are specific about
what they need do they want a news learn
a new skill do they need an introduction
how do you help them so it's really
about being prepared for that job search
yeah it's interesting you say that uh
people there's no Stigma associated with
it the survey says it most people think
there is a stigma you say not to take it
personal it's hard not to take it
personal and you say there is no Stigma
what do you mean about being laid off
yeah so what happened is during covid
when people you know companies were
laying people off shedding jobs other
you know industries were hiring all of a
sudden there was this kind of Reckoning
in terms of like you know stuff happens
businesses go up and down and it's not
about you personally and you also
sometimes need to take time off so that
you can take care of a family member and
so this concept of like oh you know you
have this you know Mark on you is is
gone and I you know really you're seeing
this with all these posts on LinkedIn
about people asking for help we're
starting to see a trend of people
becoming more comfortable when people
are having success using LinkedIn to
find a job what are they doing right
they are leaning into their Network they
are using the open to work on their
profile so that signals to recruiters
that they're available they're brushing
up on their skills this is really
important is that it's you can get a job
in an industry that you're not used to
working in if you have the right skills
take an inventory of what skills you
have take a look at the jobs that you're
interested in do a match of where those
gaps are get those skills right away and
start storytelling of how you've applied
to skills to your job you mentioned the
career cushion kind of idea that you
prepare for this by making sure things
are in order what do you mean by that
exactly you know it's it's
the year because that's overwhelming at
least I
but it's about always making sure you're
ready to go your you know your resume is
up to date you've been keeping your your
contacts warm you know exactly what you
want in your career you're up to date on
those skills and you know career
cushioning is good in this layoff
situation it's also good if you're
confident in your job because a new job
opportunity could come your way and you
want to be ready it's just good to be
ready yeah you're going to be ready they
open all possibilities thank you
Catherine fish always good to have
appreciate it very important information